time now for the uplift at eight where
we share stories that will bring some
joy to your day we could all use that
vlad what do you guys think can we all
use a little bit of joy yes i always say
the uplift is gonna be the best thing
you're gonna see all day it's live
they'd really enjoy if you use this
camera
okay
no i thought you were reagan over there
all right i'm gonna look over here now
uh i think shantae said i'm the director
yes
we know nothing you were given the point
i thought he was missing it all right
here we go i'm the stage manager here
tonight the smile's big are you looking
here am i looking there i'm looking here
tony nobody's getting me in trouble here
all right it's already an uplifting day
uh this morning i've got a special way
to say yes to the dress gwendolyn stool
just worked really really hard to find
her dream wedding dress but after buying
it for three thousand dollars she had an
idea
i didn't really want to keep the dress
um i felt no need to put it in a box and
save it i think i decided a month or so
after i bought it that i didn't want it
and i was going to give it away
so after saying i do in may gwyndolin
posted on facebook that she wanted to
give it to a bride who deserves the
dress of her dreams but can't afford one
or had to settle for something in their
own price range the only condition the
taker must have it quote dry clean and
passed on to another woman to keep the
tradition going for as long as the dress
can stand after sifting through dozens
of responses gwendolyn found margaret
hyde who is thrilled to wear the dress
of her dreams
complete shock and awe
it didn't hit till later on in that day
i was actually going to end up making my
own dress i would never have been able
to afford a dress that expensive
ah so gwendolyn also created the
facebook group shared dream dresses get
this it has hundreds of members and is
helping people share everything from
bridal gowns to tuxedos for ring bearers
which i think is a wonderful idea i love
it when things work out that way and it
is a gorgeous dress it really is it
really is congratulations